le parcours de la flamme olympique a été
révélé ce vendredi midi allumé en Grèce
à Olympie elle arrivera le 8 mai 2020 4
par la mer à Marseille avant de se
lancer dans un périple qu'il a fera
traverser une soixantaine de
départements
l'Indre-et-Loire a décliné car il
fallait débourser 150.000 euros hors
taxe pour l'avoir passé le Loir-et-Cher
a fait le choix inverse alors quel sera
son parcours pourrez-vous l'admirer à
Blois Chambord ou Cheverny le point avec
Faustine Luneau
pourtant le 9 juillet 2024 c'est la date
à retenir une journée durant laquelle la
flamme olympique traverse sera le
Loir-et-Cher comme 63 autres
départements français le 41 fait partie
du tracé un événement qui coûte 180000
euros toute taxe comprise au conseil
départemental malgré l'enveloppe
participé était une évidence pour les
élus il était pour nous important de
mettre ses valeurs du sport en avant et
ses valeurs aussi d'unités nationales
par rapport à ce que représente le
passage de la flamme donc il y a pas eu
d'hésitation les élus ont voté très
largement ce dispositif d'ailleurs 64
départements c'est quand même la
majorité des départements qui
accueillent la flamme parmi les 15
propositions du département cette ville
ont été sélectionnées par le comité
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour le passage de la
flamme des choix évidents comme Blois
Vendôme ou Romorantin les trois plus
grosses villes du département ou encore
Chambord et Chaumont-sur-Loire connu
pour leur château mais aussi des choix
plus inattendus comme frais de Vald et
Thésée très agréablement surpris parce
que je pense que en fait si on réfléchit
bien ça s'y prête complètement la flamme
olympique va rentrer dans le site
gallo-romain quoi c'est inespéré pour
nous les retransmissions vont aller
au-delà de nos frontières et puis il y a
une méconnaissance de notre site c'est
vrai donc ça sera un plus pour nous une
vitrine pour ces communes mais aussi une
occasion historique de créer du lien
entre les acteurs de leur territoire
nous proposerons probablement au mois de
septembre à l'ensemble des associations
une réunion pour voir comment chacun
peut s'associer et comment au-delà du
quart d'heure de passage qui sera
finalement assez furtif on arrive à
faire de cette journée une journée
mémorable pour tous l'ordre de traversée
de Sion l'arrivée se fera à Blois ville
étape quant au porteur de la flamme sur
les 200 Loir et syriens qui seront
sélectionnésistes doivent être choisis
par le Département leur identité n'a pas
encore été dévoilée